I'm really not lazing something because
I have a problem I am addicted to
cartoons I've been the animators
Anonymous I've checked into the Betty
Boop wing of Betty Ford I went to my
therapist not going to open the door and
said what's up doc and I realized that I
have a Jones for the work of Chuck Jones
yes or you know
are you not true he is one of the true
pioneers of animation part of the team
that gave us Looney Tunes he worked on
bugs
Daffy porky Elmer the roadrunner Wiley
coyote Pepe LePew
it sounds like the guest list at Snoop
Doggy Dogg I know Tweety and Sylvester
Tom and Jerry Siskel and Ebert they wish
he has raised speech impediments to an
art form
you cannot say despicable and not take a
Daffy Duck his characters are everywhere
that little frog even has his own
Network on The WB if you've seen the
primary's you've got to believe that his
characters are running for office yes
now doesn't Steve Forbes sound like
Marvin the Martian
some men are born great some achieve
greatness and some get it as a
graduation gift when you look at silh
grim isn't he Elmer Fudd I tried to win
the primary but did not succeed I'm Pat
Buchanan Pat Buchanan is definitely
foghorn leghorn afraid boy I'm not a
chicken I'm a hawk don't you believe me
son
now if Chuck could only animate Bob Dole
we can have an interesting campaign come
on yeah now you have to admit there's a
little bit of Chuck Jones lodged in the
frontal lobe of everyone here tonight
you know that and let me show you this
incredible body of work and tell me that
this man is not the Orson Welles of
animation
with my great pleasure to present this
very special achievement award to an
artist who's a true visionary ladies and
gentlemen put him together for the
hardest drawing man in show business
Chuck Jones
well what can I say in the face of such
humiliating evidence I stand guilty
before the world directly over 300
cartoons the last 50 or 60 years
hopefully this means you've forgiven me
in 1931 I came stumbling out of Shannara
Art Institute into the arid maelstrom of
the Great Depression
in the one hope that I can resume my
school career as a janitor a miracle
occurred so staggeringly unexpected and
unbelievable that I find it incredible
even today somebody offered to pay me to
draw and sew this miracle continues for
nearly 70 years I've been paid
adequately
if not lavishly for doing what I enjoy
doing most a miracle indeed Robert Frost
expresses it boast missed my object in
life he said is to unite my avocation
and my vocation as my two eyes are one
in sight my deepest thanks for the
signal and shining award and my love to
Marian and Linda and to the Laughing
denizens of termite Terrace wherever you
are thank you